hot breath something i always like to
ask comedians on here is like
an epic bombing story or like even to
the point where you get booed on stage
yeah i'm sure you having a drinking
regimen i'm sure
some have come up yeah epic bombs yeah
well when you're drinking it's much
easier to have a snap
set and kind of lose your mind and get
um now a little more
uh accepting of whatever sort of comes
and happens on stage but
um yeah i've told the story a few times
on podcasts but the the
most booing bomb set was opening for bob
saget oh my gosh at the university of
new hampshire
in new hampshire obviously and it was
like 3
000 kids in a gym and they were just
fired up to see
saggit and the show started about an
hour late because there was a problem
with the fire marshal but they had all
the kids outside
and it was in like february in new
hampshire so it was freezing
and then when it was time to start the
show they were literally chanting saggit
and like stomping on the bleachers
and it was like the classic comedy
formula when the guy comes out and he's
like are you ready
and it was like and then they was like
well first we have an opener
joe list and they started booing like
immediately and
um it was like 3 000 kids or maybe
whatever 1500 kids however
many were booing but people booing and
really it was uh
it was a melee but um but it was fun
that one it actually wasn't that bad
because i knew that they were kind of
booing
the fact that it wasn't bob saget mm-hmm
and it wasn't really the material it was
like they listened to my material i'm
like wait a minute
boom they're just booing like [__] this
guy and then at one point some guy
yelled out hey [__] bring out saggett
and that was actually
uh that was actually pretty enjoyable i
was like well that was fun
yeah uh not that i condone that language
but you're like well you're gonna throw
a rhyme in there
that was fun uh and saget loved it he
was laughing and uh
i was supposed to do like 20 and i ended
up doing like you know 14 and i remember
turning to the side of the stage
like can i wrap this and they kind of
had took pity on me and were like
so i said mercy and left but uh that was
definitely
the most booing situation i did comedy
in a gym one time like a gold's gym
this guy that ran a gym had an idea to
like have comedy during it
so there's a bunch of like you know
bodybuilders behind me like dropping the
leg press
and then like you know married women
on like the elliptical machine like
headphones and be like what the hell's
this [__] talking about
and that was pretty bad so there was
been definitely a bunch of weird bad
yeah i mean there's always bad shows
with comedy yeah that's that's why i
always like to ask comedians because we
all have those stories
it's funny that the guy's like you being
a comedian you're like show to gold's
gym that's a terrible idea
i'll do it right you know well that was
interesting because this was like
maybe like two years into my career when
i was 19 or 20 or whatever
and that actually my buddy was telling
me it was his gig
and i was like i'll open he was like i
gotta do a half hour at a gym
and i was like give me 20 bucks i'll do
10 minutes in front of you and he was
like
of course yes and uh so that was like it
wasn't even like
a hell gig that i was asked to do i
begged my way on to a gig at a gym it
was pretty
but i at the time i wanted to uh now i
feel like i'm past that point but i
wanted to do comedy
every way to experience i did the naked
show one time and i
accommodated a gym and i've done it like
rock and roll i was like i want to do
every
form of stand-up and then after a
certain point
that's no longer beneficial to you i
think
like doing bad shows is no longer like
oh this will help me
but early on i think it does how long
into your career did it take you before
you realized okay maybe i don't need to
be doing the 2 a.m show at a coffee shop
yeah probably a while i mean i think
10 12 years i think if you're making a
living i mean it's like all right
but if you're you know if you're not
maybe just keep getting in wherever you
can because it all
helps i guess mm-hmm